what's going on everybody it's warren
and the one division trailer came out
watching it for the very first time
let's do this
[Music]
this is our home now i want us to fit in
oh this is gonna be a gas where did you
two move from
how long have you been married and why
don't you have children then
our story i think what my wife means to
say is that we move
move from where married went damn it why
oh arthur stop it stop it
stop it
no why would you think that because you
are
we are an unusual couple you know oh i
don't think that was ever in question
oh my god
okay wow um so at this point
i kind of don't have any doubt that
agatha harkness is the person that is
actually
creating these different we'll call them
realities
for rwanda and vision we could see how
in the end there kind of went backwards
vision is super confused he has no idea
how he's alive
so maybe he gets brought back to life
maybe then they go into a different
reality
maybe he gets brought back to life
another reality but it's the same
consciousness
i'm not sure we're going to have to
watch this a lot more times and break it
down
and see what it's about but it looks
absolutely epic
it looks kind of what i thought it was
going to look like debbie drew up is
hilarious
and overall it just looks like it's
going to be a truly amazing show so let
me know what you thought about our first
look
at the wanda vision trailer let me know
what you think of the comments down
below
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof